back home after more than 200 years in
the Netherlands these artifacts were
looted by Dutch soldiers when they
overran the palace in Candi in central
Sri Lanka in
1765 these items were made for the king
we have very few of those now remaining
so these are very important
artifacts the items are now on display
at Columbus National
Museum they include these two guns
weighing 28 kilos each
the mobile Heavy Artillery was used by
troops of the Candian King to defend the
city and the palace the most
eye-catching item of the collection is
the L Cannon named after the Aristocrat
who had it decorated for the king it is
a very hybrid object it was probably
made in the Netherlands then given to
the king of Sri Lanka later it was
embellished decorated in Sri Lanka and
then given to the King again uh and then
it was taken uh away experts say most of
the items were made in Royal workshops
of the Candian Kingdom and are a
testament to the skill of The Artisans
of the
time they are the first ever Colonial
artifacts returned by the Dutch
government it's very important to look
at critically uh reflect on the history
and uh to well take steps in uh doing
things right which went in a history
wrong the Sri Lankan government says it
is grateful for the return of its
artifacts by the Netherlands which has
been more helpful than other former
Colonial Powers uh we wrote to a another
European country asking to give uh
electronic copies of um of manuscripts
uh pertaining to a and they s sent us a
note saying that you know they will be
charging 30,000 rupees 30,000
so and I see the irony of this these are
stolen items we are not even asking them
back balua says he hopes the moral
example set by the Dutch government will
influence others to return culturally
significant items to their rightful
owners it's taken more than 40 years to
get these Colonial artifacts back to Sri
Lanka The Collection is a fraction of
the thousands of treasures looted and
plundered and now found in museums
around the world historians say the
return is a welcome start Mel Fernandez
Al jazer
Columbo make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer